all right so it's monday morning i am
back in the geisel library in the aurora
sansom collection and getting ready for
the day I've already been in here about
half an hour just doing the typical
morning tidying things up taking care of
emails thanking subscribers on YouTube
addressing a few comments here and there
got up this morning ready to to have a
sort of leisurely morning and then head
up the hill and hit the ground running
as it turned out the the crews that are
putting in the windows were ready to
work on our building around seven ten or
so so as i was making coffee they are
knocking on the door wanting to come in
they had their machines going and
fortunately for me as i put on one of my
facebook comments and google+ comments
the smell of diesel exhaust actually the
morning has a nostalgic connotation for
me it reminds me of my my days when i
was in the 16th engineer battalion which
was a mechanized unit part of the 1st
Armored Division back at when I was a
kid you know kid like 19 20 years old in
in Germany so it doesn't really you know
get to me that much and I can work in
you know a lot of circumstances that are
not ideal for most academics so I you
know we doing some reading eating my
muffins and having my coffee so I could
feel awake and alive and then I you know
took shower got dressed started getting
ready to head out and I got into a
conversation with one of the the guys
who was working
not actually on the crew he's a
subcontractor as it turns out we talked
for about 15 minutes I'd run into him in
the parking lot on Friday and he thought
that I was a musician because I was
carrying my my tripod in the case which
i suppose looks like an instrument case
so we got to we got to chatting on
Friday for a couple minutes and I gave
him my card and you know he was
interested when he found out that i did
youtube videos on philosophy thought it
was a cool thing and so I you know said
well you know check them out so he was
the guy who was up there working you
know briefly in the apartment and then
in the stairwell he does some of their
their their finer you know more complex
work for that that company and we got to
talking and turns out that he's from the
area but he also has you know homes down
and in Florida because he's engaged he
seems like a very busy guy he's engaged
and you know buying and flipping and and
you know always on the on the make so to
speak and we talked about quite a few
topics i like having conversations with
with ordinary people non academics who
have you know some interesting stories
to tell and some interesting insights
about what's going on so that's that's
really where at least if you're doing
philosophy particularly moral philosophy
that's where you need to stay grounded
likewise you know if you're just talking
to fellow academics you're kind of
limiting your your scope and your
relevance and you're probably not doing
is philosophy as well you know somebody
who I think about who not only writes
about that as a problem but really
exemplifies that in his own life in his
practice is Alistair McIntyre who he's
kind of like a Socrates type in that way
he'll spill Hill have conversations once
you get past the you know kind of
somewhat dour seeming at times exterior
he's very jovial and and willing to
engage in you know very thoughtful and
interest in conversations with
with all sorts of people and you can
tell that it really paid dividends for
his work as a philosopher all right so
enough chitchat about the morning and
speculations about sippy what have I got
going on today busy day I think the
library is open until six o'clock or
eight o'clock so I've got a full day
ahead in the morning I'm going through
abstracts as soon as I finish this I'm
going through abstracts till about you
know 12 30 or so not gotten it going
through abstracts going through
dissertations and writing abstracts and
then in the afternoon well that I'm
going to have lunch and I need to do a
few things during launch like come up
with my my questions for interviews do a
little reading I brought some-some
Thomas Aquinas on the emotions to go
back over because I'm going to start
working on that paper a bit later today
well here it is right here fear and
anger and you know confidence and
despair and hope as well the emotions
that deal with the difficult good so
that's that's up to the afternoon and
then in the afternoon around two o'clock
kevin mcmahon and Monty Brown are coming
over and I'm going to interview them
here in the geisel library room I've
already also got locked in father John
fortin so that's at least three people
being interviewed for the the video
about you know the Saint Anselm
Institute and its work and its history
i'm hoping i can get James Rourke when
he's here for the conference i'm also
hoping i can get Kevin Staley he's a
hard guy to catch I'm going to give him
a call actually right after i get off of
this video and then after those those
videos are done i need to i'll probably
should check in you know by here with
with the video thing but then i need to
hunker down
and go through all the Marcel related
materials that I gathered from the
library stacks looking for stuff for the
the article on Marcel and the Christian
philosophy debates that I started
writing last night and made about you
know three four solid pages of progress
on that's right so part of it is coming
from this this book which is my book
where I actually have a whole section
devoted to Marcel yeah here it is
regarding the spirit of medieval
philosophy by Monsieur Etienne Jill saw
in la nouvelle revue de jeune 1932 we
did some book reviews Jill Psalms a
spirit of medieval philosophy which is
Gifford lectures at the time very
important intervention so writing that
for the the new journal that was started
by the Gabriella Marcel society don't
know if they have their first issue out
but if I can get it done on time then it
can be in the first issue which would be
really cool if not be in the second
issue which is also pretty cool too one
of my areas of work you know not only do
i work on Marcel is an existentialist
and as to a certain degree of virtue
ethicist but he also plays a role in
these important Christian philosophy
debates that I I work on so that's
that's what I'm going to be doing and be
working on Marcel stuff probably reading
my way through some other and some
related things as well having to do with
prayer and outlining my my Thomas
Aquinas talk which is coming up in about
two and a half weeks so that's what's
slated for the day I don't even know
what's going on in the evening I'll
worry about that later on in the day so
it's Monday afternoon it's about 135 or
so day 6 since the morning where I got a
lot of work done on
writing abstracts and providing key
terms for some of these dissertations
very happy about then went to noon
prayer with the monks and one other
layperson it's part of the liturgy of
the hours that the the monks a daily I
used to say the Liturgy of the hours
daily and I found it to be very valuable
and I like the way that the monks do it
in a very slow contemplative way not
like the rushing that I not intend to do
unfortunately when I when I do say it
and then after that I had a little chat
with the other guy who was there who
turned out to be a professor a retired
professor in theology then went to have
lunch did some texting with my my wife
about her day and read some Thomas
Aquinas primarily on the emotion of hope
and how it works I then went to the
bookstore and the business office just
to like and I'll see what they had in
the bookstore maybe buy some things for
my kids and my wife and to see whether
they they had my check ready for my per
diem and travel and you know got the
information from from them about that
then I went to the library and I had a
little chat with one of the librarians
and she clued me into a book a poor kind
history of philosophy and religion which
has several parts classic Greek pigs
pigs of the ancient medieval church
Protestant pigs modern philosophical
pigs and 21st century pigs so I'll
probably take some snapshots of these
because if they're pretty funny and i'll
upload them later on today so in about
20 minutes or so Monty Brown and kevin
mcmahon are going to be here and I'm
planning on shooting some interview
footage with them talking about the
Saint Anselm Institute and their
involvement in it and what you know the
Institute does and and what they've got
coming up
since its you know pretty cool
institution so I'm just preparing now
some of my questions for them and
getting my my head right for that I
think I might do a little bit of work
looking at this this particular
dissertation non-existence modalities
and Anselm's ontological argument if I
if I can get some of that you know dug
through and and get some of the
abstracting done for it some of the
keywords done for it before I actually
get to doing interviews otherwise after
that we're looking at an afternoon in
which I'm going to continue doing some
of this read some more dissertations
that have to do with my own particular
topics that I'm working on with the ants
um and I'm going to dig into a stack of
Gabrielle Marcel works and secondary
literature on him that I've gotten out
of the stacks that I want to like dig I
want to go through in order to find
references to some of the issues that
I'm writing about in my article that I'm
working on while I'm here as well so
busy day but it's going along quite well
it's kind of overcast it's good day to
be inside and check in later on
if you've been watching these you've
heard me mention noon prayer a few times
and so I wanted to take you on a little
trip to the saint anselm abbey church so
that you could actually see the the
space in which we're doing that because
this is a really wonderful piece of
architecture and the stained glass is
really amazing from an artistic
perspective which is very important
people often think that you know
monasteries are just about asceticism
but for the Benedict envision here's the
the main worship space that it's very
important to have a place like this
simple and yet beautiful this is where
they have the masses and in the back is
where they do the Liturgy of the hours
here's some of the stained glass windows
from the back part which has a bunch of
pews where where we sit and do the
Liturgy of the hours this is one of
three of the main windows this
represents the first person of the
Trinity and it's its creation bringing
order out of out of nothing this is the
second person of the Trinity you can see
a if you know what to look for here is
from a representation of baptism and
here we have the Holy Spirit the third
person of the Trinity the traditional
red as the tongues of fire coming down
again here's some more of the stained
glass windows from the area where the
Liturgy of the hours are prayed and now
I'm going to take you past some of the
windows so you can actually see the
workmanship close up this is exiting the
the church on the explosive you're
facing out it would be the right side
you can see just how intricate and how
much work went into these these
beautiful compositions now we're
actually approaching my favorite one of
these lower windows quite sure why it's
my favorite would be hard put to give a
description
the morning of day 7 Tuesday this is the
second to last morning that I will be
waking up here and having well I'm not
going to have breakfast here because i'm
actually out of muffins I'm out of juice
and out of coffee i'm actually having
tea this morning so yeah I'll just have
breakfast up at the cafe next time this
is my last full day of work on this this
residency because the meta physics
colloquium starts tomorrow so that is
going to end effectively my time using
the library because we'll be very busy
you know in the presentations and
talking with the other participants I
have to pack up everything tonight and
so I can move out in the morning because
I'll be staying in another dorm where
they put all of us colloquium
participants much closer to the Dana
center just a short walk across a
parking lot as opposed to the you know
about five to ten minute walk from here
so I didn't get as much done as i would
have liked yesterday in part because by
the time that i got home around six
o'clock i was pretty wiped out i had
some you know some dinner and then just
you know i read a bit watched a few
shows on hulu talked with my wife and
then crashed out pretty early which is
good because i'm more rested today
haven't slept all that well except for
last night the entire time that I've
been here you know how it is once your
your body's in your 40s different beds
different environments it's hard to get
good sleep and then that takes kind of a
toll so I'm feeling very very rested but
I'm also feeling anxious about getting
as much work done as possible because
I'm the kind of guy who tends to have a
lot of projects hanging and I can feel
them you know almost palpably on my back
gotten quite a bit you know I
polish up the paper on courteous homo
sent that off to Monte and Kevin I've
got my presentation ready for my my talk
on Saturday about epicureans and anger
all I need to do is create some handouts
for that and I'll probably do that when
I get home I'll do that friday or so
I've gotten a lot of video content shot
including some interview video with
Monty and Kevin but also you know
sitting in Psalms proce proce logie own
some Hagel stuff I think I'll shoot some
more Hagel possibly tonight so that I've
got that in you know in reserve as I'm
moving ahead what else you know we've
got some some work done on the Marcel
paper and I've started outlining my
Thomas Aquinas anger paper which I won't
actually be reading as such i'll be
presenting the paper which means that
i'll i'll give sort of a summary but i
need i still need to have something
written for for those who want something
written and because the papers are going
to be included in an anthology i think
if i remember right if not i'll just
publish it somewhere else so today a lot
of work ahead it's almost eight o'clock
and i need to get really moving in a
minute i am currently you know going
through emails my students will have
handed in i'm actually still teaching an
online ethics class as well so it hasn't
been a complete break and students often
need a lot of hand-holding surprisingly
a surprising amount of it so that's been
taking up some time so I'm gonna have to
do some grading because I like to
especially early in the semester it's
very important to get feedback to
students right away so if they're
they're not doing things right they can
start you know realizing that and start
paying attention to the the materials
that they've been given and start doing
things correctly usually it takes the
sting of one bad grade to bring that
home and then for those who are actually
on the right track
a lot of them you know need confirmation
that hey you're doing the right thing
keep this up so I may have to do some
grading today hopefully going to get
some some writing done and as far as
video work goes I will probably wait
till I come back here to the apartment
before i do any of that other than these
sort of video updates during the day
alright I'm back in the Institute it is
around 10 20 and I've got a stack of
Marcel related material that I'm
planning on going through skimming
combing through looking for references
to things that might have to do with the
paper I'm writing on Marcel and the
Christian philosophy debates and the
broader issue of Marcel's conception of
Christian philosophy at twelve o'clock
i'm going to head back over to the
chapel for noon prayer and then i'm
going to have some lunch at the cafe so
i've got a bit of time to do this
library is open till six no yeah six
today so i do have enough time to go
through and continue doing some of the
documentation work that I need to do for
the the project that I came up here you
know commissioned by the archives and
the Saint Anselm Institute to help out
with starting to see you know light at
the end of the tunnel there's more that
that would need to be done in order to
like fully see it through but we've only
got so much time and you know we're
getting something accomplished but for
the for the moment they're off camera so
you can just hear him I've got this
stack of Marcel stuff to go through
Gabrielle Marcel is somebody who I very
much liked to read and think about it
was difficult to write on in part
because he's a non-systematic
deliberately anti systematic philosopher
so he's his writing is in many ways more
like musical movements where you have to
like see the same themes coming
been getting different treatments from
from movement to movement but he is well
worth reading he's well worth spending
time on at lunch I'm going to be
continuing my rereading of Thomas's
discussions of anger as I prepare for
that I had a great insight for how to
begin the talk I need to write it down
before I forget about it and that's
that's where we stand right now so
that's what's going on today and i'll
talk about it you know more stuff when
more stuff comes up
it's Wednesday morning day 7 the last
day of my research residency which was
unfortunately all too short but I got
quite a bit done during it I still have
two more dissertations to go through
right abstracts for do keywords one of
which is actually here we go Kate Rogers
who's a major and some scholar somebody
who had met and interacted with and who
I like quite a bit her dissertation
Saint Anselm of Canterbury on divine and
human ideas I've read through parts of
it before and I've also read her her
work the neoplatonic metaphysics and
epistemology of Anselm of Canterbury
which I've drawn on in the past so I'm
looking forward to spending well I've
got about maybe 45 minutes that I can
devote to to this one and then I've got
this one I'm not looking forward quite
so much to divine freedom which is on
you know an some and God and it has to
do with you know various views on that
and it looks like it could have been the
analytic philosophy mixed in with this
which tends to make an some quite boring
but we'll see what how it works so I
packed everything up and put it in my
car because we're going to be staying in
a different place on the other side of
campus for the meta physics colloquium
which starts this afternoon I may shoot
a bit more footage after this but this
is probably either the last or close to
last of the things that I'm going to
record for the trip so it's been very
successful and a lot of great
conversations not just with other people
involved with with an some but library
staff some of the other you know
maintenance staff who work here in
painters
some of the people in other places and
and yeah I perhaps spend a bit more time
in conversations that I ought to have
but that's really one of my you know
some of my traits so I liked people I
liked finding out about them and you
know finding out what what goes on in
their life and comparing notes and that
sort of thing I think that's an
important part of life so that's what I
do so I've got my my notes all typed up
I just have to add a few more things and
over the weekend they'll probably be
producing the report for for the
archivist Keith chevallier wasn't able
to be here because he had a child born
over this this period was really good
for him and his wife but I'm going to be
developing a rapport advising the the
center on you know what are their
dissertations they might want to get
where they can find the abstracts for
for quite a few of these dissertations
although that's going to involve some
data entry on their part which is kind
of kind of boring stuff and then giving
them a number of abstracts and keywords
for quite a few of these these
dissertations that they've got so it's
it's going to be quite quite useful for
them looking forward to the meta physics
colloquium starting to this time it's
actually about artwork aesthetics and
beauty so an area where I've got some
real interests but I've never really
done much much writing and sometimes
feel a little bit out of my element so
it's going to be pretty good do some
more interviews as well this is one with
Kevin Staley a little bit later today
hopefully with Jim Roark and I've got
father John fortin down for an interview
in this space on Thursday tomorrow the
last day of the of the colloquium
you